投資變換收聽,早晨財經速解讀。
現在是臺北時間,2026年8月17日禮拜一,早上8點31分。
大家早安,我是劉廷浩。
每天早上開文件半小時,我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經新聞時事變化。
上禮拜五,
美國最新的零售交收數據和消費者的信心還是有非常明顯的降溫,
但至少把升息的警報給解除了,
看看有沒有機會在今年沒有任何升息一碼的機會。
當然回過頭說
如果按照目前的財富效應
要馬上打開接下來的降息通道
也有所難度
這一次7月份零售銷售數據的下滑
能不能至少為降息的方向來奠定基礎呢
雖然華許一直說
他不願意做任何的前瞻指引
但至少在接下來的FOMC
應該要適度表態了
回過頭說
標普500指數到目前為止
財富效應還是撐住了整體的經濟概況
標普現在是接近有8000點
距離200日移動平均線
我們把它當做年線
還高出了接近有10%
距離50日均線也高出了3.7%
有72%的成分股
目前已經占上了年線
市場廣度依舊還是很健康的
基本面也確實有支撐
這一次第二季的企業獲利年增幅
就算不看AI巨頭
整體增長幅度大概都有33%
未來預估本益比
10月份去年
AI用動機當時的高點還有23倍
標普500信貸的本益比值
剩下20倍
所以你就清楚知道
這一波的上漲
它不是靠估值膨脹
是靠基本面的推動
其實基本面上升的速度
比資金買盤還要來得更為快速
重點在於整個7月份
你不要看豐生合力
韓國股市散戶
我記得有30萬戶爆倉
120萬人受到市場協助承壓
不過在7月份
美國的家庭單月的ETF流入金額
高達了3500億美元
今年已經高達1.6兆了
說明雖然短線上
這個來客自如
就是有些乘客上車
有些乘客下車
可是從長線上
幾乎所有存股族都在7月份加大扣款
那高盛的年終目標是8000點
距離現在的點位
大概也只剩下3%左右的幅度
所以從這樣的一個角度來做觀察
的確標普白指數
在上禮拜所創下的歷史新高
仍然是讓美國股市
保持在高強度多頭的根本原因
標普上禮拜已經第27次創下歷史新高了
如果從13年來看
已經是470次了
你有沒有發現
過去10年除了2023年沒有創高以外
大多數的年份幾乎都在創高
所以美國股市的三代牛慣性
還是很明顯的
不要跟著它對坐
就連過去最為疲憊沉寂的微軟
最近都已經硬起來了
準備要往歷史高點來做邁進
你看當時他的頭部打了多久
結果這一段時間財報季之後
股價大漲
嘗試著要把過去的市場賣壓
一舉的殲滅
軟鐵股也是如此
大家還記得今年年初
其實股價也在跌
只是當時的跌法
跌幅主要都是集中在一些軟鐵股
我們講的SARS末日
因為這些軟鐵股會被Agent AI
被Agent AI給取代
可是我們看到一個月前
軟鐵股還是市場最討厭
最放空然後最擁擠
估值也最便宜的族群
現在的高強度反彈
你發現IGV軟體型ETF
一個月它已經漲兩成了
如果從四月的低點來看其漲點
已經漲40%了
距離歷史高點
它漲幅也不到10%了
所以就連過去最為疲憊的軟體股
都開始蠢蠢欲動
我們很明顯感受到
只要讓晶片股稍微休息一下
資金就開始迴流到科技巨頭
或者這些軟體型ETF當中
當然很多人會說
可是距離期中選舉躍進
好像也不以股市持續走高
的確按照過往經驗
VIC指數的確在8月到9月
通常會創下當年度的波段低點
在期中選舉年
可是當9月來到10月之後
會有慣性的走高
所引起的進一步中期回調
主要來自於
有時候選情會相對比較焦灼
所以會讓政策的不確定性大幅提高
我們不確定這次期中選舉之後
川普會不會就會有被彈劾的壓力
所以在這樣的一個效果底下
等同於
雖然今年已經經歷了兩次
比較大的中期回調
時間先不長了
但有沒有可能出現第三次呢
也許還是有一段的時間
至少我們從現在來看
整體美國股市
其實從7月份以後
它還是一個標準的肋骨的輪動
只是有些肋骨輪動大了一點
看起來就變成
進入到熊市或者中期回調了
但你不要想說
那晶片股現在就很慘了
不要碰晶片股了
晶片股的反彈其實也很快了
我們必須承認
晶片股即便今年跌這麼重
仍然在漲幅當中是名列前茅的
我們以標普500指數來看
今年漲幅最亮麗的股票
幾乎還是AI基礎建設概念股
Cendex你不要看前陣子跌這麼重
今年是漲了591%
戴爾漲了294%
希傑漲了254%
美光241%
Intel178%
威騰196%
AND140%
這都是今年漲幅低於100%都算輸
而且在這一些股價上漲的過程當中
它並沒有導致科技股嚴重的估值失真
因為獲利成長的速度更快
所以如果我們看納斯達克100指數
從7月份低點這樣子彈上來
大概彈了12%
占上了50日均線
它距離歷史高點只剩下2%
可是你看它的本益比
如果是以前佔本益比來看
現在大概是22.5倍
哇
這個水準是比過去五年都低
你看去年高點
10月份AI永動機是28倍
2024年的高點是27倍
2023年也有27.5倍
所以現在的機器
跟大家分享
跟烏二戰士差不多
納斯達克指數
你願不願意在烏二戰士
有可能開打之後
可能價格修正更大
你願不願意在2022年買進股票
你現在就願不願意在2026年買進股票
當然我們是抱持左側邏輯
最好等市場相對悲觀
可是你至少可以看得出來
從基期角度而言
2026年的股票
比過去23年24年25年都要便宜
那平移的程度
差不多等於2022年的平均值
這就是真實市場的概況
而且本輪的上漲也稍微比較健康了
不像過去這麼極端
以前是如果你買個股
你只要沒有買到七巨頭
你大概就跑出大盤了
現在不一樣
現在已經有75%的成分股
都已經占上了200日的移動平均線
創下2024年10月份以來的新高
所以這一次是廣泛性的上漲
沒有漲幅這麼極端了
當然現在從7月份的驅槓桿
現在重新加槓桿
有沒有可能重蹈覆轍
這很難說
有沒有可能5、6月份
大家的信心又重新歸來
然後又上槓杆
這個要繼續觀察資金流的變化
但至少可以承認
本人的上漲相對於以往幾年
比較健康
第一本益比低
第二上漲的寬度正在明顯的擴散
如果你把AI拿掉
的確好像美國企業的獲利沒這麼強
可是美國企業獲利
已經連續三年翻證了
現在就是如果有AI
這個基礎建設概念股的拉昇
大概整體成長
今年第二季財報是54%
越成長越誇張
那如果你把
這個基礎建設概念股給拿掉
那大概就剩下14%
那你說14%很差嗎
其實還是過去六個季度以來的最高
所以從這件事情都看得出來
為什麼波克夏這次所公佈的13F
願意開始採購
因方面當然是巴菲特交棒了
所以現在是阿貝爾主導
他有自己的投資風格
那這一次大幅的買入股票200億
創下現金部位
從2022年以來最快的下滑記錄
那買最多的第一個就Google
因為本益比真的偏低
已經變成波克夏的第三大持股了
其他像是達美航空
或者一些房屋建商等等
這些持續性的投資都說明著
波克夏的價值投資思維
已經開始套用了
對他們來講
機器已經逐步到位
也許整個大盤
他覺得可以更便宜
但很多個股
已經吸引他
持續的來做買入
所以有時候
我們自以為聰明
往往比無知更危險
這句話在投資市場當中
就是讓我們瞭解
至少自己不懂的話
反而會保守一點
最危險的就是
你好像看懂了一些財報
總體經濟數據
就覺得自己
好像完全看懂了市場
有時候你覺得
你早知道了
但是有時候市場上
在不同的數據當中
你經由數據比對之後
反而得出了一個比較鮮明的例子
就是股價雖然現在是高強度牛市
可是從所有指標來看
你似乎都看不到嚴重的及其時針
這就是真實概況
你真正擔憂的
都是擔憂那個前頭太多回不來的問題
這的確值得擔憂
可是你擔憂現在股票很貴
那就不一定了
所以這是從不同角度來做思維的
當然回過頭說
現在在各大資產當中漲幅來得最多的
第一名仍然是大宗資產
34.2%漲幅第一名
肖興股漲24.5%
今年以來價值股漲23%
可轉債20.6%
中型股19.4%
納斯達克100有19.3%
成熟股是現在14.9%
成熟市場標普500是14.5%
瑞茲漲13%
那大部分都還是掙報酬
少數真的表現相對比較差勁的
一個是長天級國債
不過它跌3.3%也不算特別重
領息搞不好這幾年領的回來
投資整季債是下跌1.1%
深圳跌最重的又是你比特幣
跌幅是28%
比特幣這兩年確實比較慘一點
波動也比有時候比股票
比債券市場傳統市場還要來得更為劇烈
但如果把時間拉長
我還是相信比特幣最終還是會反映
全球貨幣的供給和流動性長期擴張的趨勢
我其實沒有這麼悲觀
其實不只比特幣
大多數具有生產力
有稀缺性
抗通膨的優質資產
只要你不是單一個股
單一標的
你只要經濟繼續成長
大多數資產貨幣量長期增長
都能夠創高的
這是我的看法
因為最後比的是資金流
比的是貨幣總量
投資到最後
其實這就變成了
你其實是在比時間
就你能不能熬得過去
即便它跌這麼重
我也不認為它一路就這樣跌下去了
畢竟它還是屬於定量資產
最重要的是
你還是要顧好自己的身體
因為複利需要的不是幾個月
你要10年20年甚至更久
只要資產配置做對
不要在中途被淘汰掉
不要被洗掉
剩下最大的關鍵就是身體健康
所以大家一定要活得夠長
一定要活得夠久
因為最近有很多
不是很厲害的一些前輩們
陸續離開從以前黃董
後來我一想到
看人家在講
你像張忠謀先生已經95歲了
魏德嘉先生魏董已經73歲了
然後陳泰明69歲
施政榮81歲了
曹董79歲了
郭臺銘也75歲了
不是不禮貌嗎
就是如果我們要看到AI的大爆發
你甚至都沒辦法期待這些人
陪伴著我們一起大爆發
因為畢竟壽命是有限的
可是你看黃仁勳才幾歲
他才60幾歲
潘董潘建成才60幾歲
所以這些人就可以陪伴我們
二十年三十年
所以有時候我們要講說
時間拉得越長
你就要越瞭解
那個Jason每天在說的話是什麼
因為他還要活很長
他要對自己說的話負責
但有些人
其實他早就可以享清福了
我們要回過頭來看
我們的年輕
我們的時間線
其實要比想象中還要拉得更遠
讓負力效果發揮它的效果
在AI的浪潮當中
我們也許是有機會
因為Z世代和Y世代
我記得是比前一代
還要更為貧窮的
體感上貧窮
物質上不一定
體感上比上一代更貧窮的
也許我們有機會
在這一代產生明顯的轉捩點
如果搭上AI行情的話
這我的看法
因為時間只要拉得夠長
因為真正能夠留在
贏家榜上的公司也非常少了
但是如果他已經待了好幾十年
而且已經用事實來證明他的厲害
也許我認為
那就值得相信他的話
所以我是相信Jensen說的話
為什麼這樣講
因為如果你是從過去五年
過去10年過去15年來看看輝達的報酬
它是少數一直在榜上的
輝達過去5年的總報酬是1019%
10年大概是14468%
15年是76248%
20年是63261%
不管是在過去5年10年15年20年
它都是榜單當中漲幅第一
所以它就是過去20年一直漲一直漲一直漲
當然中間會有非常多的波動
你要能夠留在市場當中
那這些人都已經證明了
不管是在以前在做顯卡做遊戲
到後來的AI浪潮
他做的事情
他其實也早就已經可以享清福了
但他仍然在第一線
鼓勵大家擁抱AI
這是非常值大家關注的重點
好那這是第一個角度
我們看待一下
股票市場在過去一週的表現
第二個角度是
市場上的壓力仍然存在
是什麼原因導致
我們希望股票可以創高
可是本益比又不願意給它高評價
這肯定跟利率環境有關
因為在上禮拜原油價格
周漲幅又高達了接近有6%
布蘭特原油現在是每桶收在88塊
希德州大概82塊
就卡在這樣的一個區間
雖然相對於今年3月到5月好很多
可是相對於去年一整年
大家看一下基期
去年的平均油價真的就是五六十塊
現在就一直維持在80
那也是一個極大的通膨壓力
雖然上禮拜
公佈的美國PPI算是明顯降溫
月增幅是零
可是我們還是要必須瞭解到
這種通膨的外溢效果
它會導致利率環境無法鬆綁
那會讓接下來這些七巨頭的
融資預期 融資規劃
稍受到極大的沉壓
我們從目前通膨數據來看也是如此
目前美加侖汽油價格大概4.07塊
跟2022年差不多
但是還是明顯比23年
24年 25年都還要來得高
所以通膨它一直以來都是一個
明顯的年增作用
而且我們必須承認
這次通膨到底有沒有外溢效果
一個月沒有
兩個月沒有
三個月沒有
超過四個月差不多就要有了
其實從伊朗戰事爆發以來
各大大宗資產的上漲幅度
其實不小
所以不能夠僅僅說
因為石油價格只有它漲
所以其他沒問題
其實大多數資產價格
都有非常明顯的外溢
漲最多是硫磺價格
145%
歐洲天然氣價格
從228到現在漲了92%
取暖油65%
航空燃油50%,柴油45%,汽油37%,稻米34%,棉花29%
那一系列聚酯纖維也受到這種油料耗材的一個損失
或者供應的衝擊而進一步上漲
棕櫚油也上漲了16%,小麥上漲14%
當然啦,如果你是用年增幅來看
就直接用去年來進行對照
漲幅有的就更為極端了
取暖油是漲了92%,白銀漲了72%,汽油52%
銅價也漲了47%
白金32
鑫價漲了32%
黃金32
小麥29
鋁價27
棉花26%
玉米23
黃豆15%
哇 都是雙位數字成長
你說有沒有稍微好一點的數據
有 咖啡只漲2%
活牛跌了2%
木材跌了7%
可可跌了34%
可是你要知道
目前你看到這些在跌價的
很多都是這幾年已經漲很多的
然後現在開始稍微回檔而已
他其實從體感上根本感覺不出來
價格下跌
比如說咖啡豆木材價格
前兩年那個飆到很離譜
甚至像是美國牛肉價格
疫情以來價格都已經翻了三倍了
以前我們臺灣
以前吃美國牛還有點顧忌
剛開放的時候
現在美國人自己都不夠吃了
還要跟阿根廷進口
餐飲成本現在也被迫抬高
其實臺灣已經有很多人吃牛肉
已經習慣吃美國牛了
像我自己也慢慢開始習慣了
不管是牛排還是牛肉麵
好像有時候我也是半夜兩三點
突然很想要吃一碗熱騰騰的牛肉麵
好險我都自己煮
但是重點是
這種價格的外溢效果
它所形成的通膨僵固性
的確會讓聯準會接下來的降息通道
產生極大挑戰
尤其每一站是到目前為止
仍然沒有十足的進展
這一次每一之間的衝突
已經從短期的軍事行動
變成了長期的消耗戰
當時在去年6月的時候
大家還記得午夜之錘
37小時像一兩核射時
投下了42萬磅的炸彈
結果短短几天就結束
當時的一個軍事行動
結果現在2月打
打到現在已經打半年了
所以華許我們講說
雖然上任之後
嘗試的減少對於利率路徑的明確指引
讓市場自行判斷
但是美伊戰士又沒有一個明顯的終局
難道你要認為我們
藉由利率預期來逼你就範嗎
所以我很好奇
華許會一輩子都不願意做前瞻指引嗎
那假設我們把十年期公債值利率
做多到4.8 4.9 5%呢
你都不喊話嗎
你都不會採取一定的措施
或者一定的回應嗎
這是很重要的
因為2026年的通膨問題
它已經不是單一各國問題
它是有明顯的全球同步正在加速
你看美國CPI現在有3.4
其他我們看到像是
日本的部分
法國的部分
臺灣的部分
歐元區的部分
波蘭的部分
幾乎通膨都開始重新回到上行路徑
那央行的表態其實又來得更為重要了
更何況美國長天期殖利率
上行情況它不只反映通膨
它其實也反映的期限溢價
正在快速的上升
從7月份聯總會FOMC會議以來
30年期的殖利率
淨升幅超過100%
幾乎都可以用期限溢價來解釋
因為市場對於長期利率的預期反而還略下降
說明什麼
說明現在大家不只是單純怕利率更高
而是所有債券投資人都要求更多的補償
來承擔10年20年30年的政策路徑
原因很簡單
第一就通膨降溫了
但是有外溢效果壓力很大
第二華許刻意減少聯準會的市場前瞻之影
那我就把實質的期限溢價同步的做高
所以在這樣效果底下
那你就要看華許到底願不願意做表態了
要不然這種環境
那利率其實是很緊繃的
應該是沒辦法讓科技巨頭
能夠放寬心的去發債
當然回過頭說
地緣政治的緊張
也是讓通膨保持在高位的根本原因
我們這一次知道
伊朗戰爭加速了消耗庫存
五角大廈在上禮拜已經要求
軍火商進行全面的擴產
那不只是中東問題
烏克蘭最近跟俄羅斯的衝擊
尤其是無人機的攻勢也創下新高了
如果我們細看圖表
光是5月到6月
烏克蘭就已經成功攻擊了
俄羅斯的煉油廠16次
創下單月的新高
嚴重到美國希望烏克蘭
可以停止攻擊俄羅斯的煉油廠
以前都是俄羅斯不要做太過分
不要攻擊民用設施
尤其是烏克蘭
但是美國人叫烏克蘭人
不要再打俄羅斯的煉油設施了
為什麼
再打上去油價就壓不住了
所以打其他的
打軍用設施就好
俄羅斯的煉油廠
至少已經遭到了194次的攻擊
相對於去年同期
已經增加了11倍
當時在六月份一個月俄羅斯就已經擊落了三萬兩千架的無人機
強勢的要攻擊煉油廠
從這件事情就說明著整個俄羅斯在七月份的雲油加工量
大概已經比平常少了三分之一
對於全球通膨的外溢效果也在陸續的增高
另外一方面黑海的航運風情也在慢慢的升高
最近烏爾站是因為一直攻擊黑海的商船
土耳其籍的船隻也遭受到波及
最後土耳其已經宣佈收緊達達尼爾海峽的通行
多騷原本要前往俄羅斯的重要油品和穀物
被告知暫時不合法通行許可
必須要更長時間的一個審查
來向烏俄兩國來施加壓力
你不要打到我的船
好 這個是屬於中東的問題
還有屬於烏俄戰場的問題
嚴峻局勢的確
比想象中還要來得更為緊張
那在太平洋的另外一端
我們看日俄局勢最近也開始升溫了
普丁上禮拜
因為是踏上了日俄的爭議領土
叫做澤州島
高市早苗在上禮拜就隨即公開抗議
說此舉傷害日本的國民感情
完全無法接受
這個澤州島
它是在南千島群島
日本叫做北方領土
除了澤州島以外
日本也主張國後島
色丹島
上面這幾個島
由日本來做領土的實質管轄
不過真實的控制
目前看起來是俄羅斯
這項領土已經爭議很多年了
雙方無法遷移和平條約
但是至少雙方都不願意登島
至少可以瞭解說
還有可以溝通的空間
不過這一次普丁就直接登島了
他先前還視察
俄羅斯太平洋的艦隊
當然你說現在兩邊作戰
那不太可能
難道日俄戰爭又蠢蠢欲動了
不太可能
可是雙方一邊說談和平
一方面都在強化軍事和政治立場
所以導致整體在日本海
到北太平洋局勢再度緊張
高市在上禮拜
才剛剛正式成立日本國家情報局
叫日本CIA
由首相親自領導的國家情報會議
因為日本以前
它是沒有國家情報局的
在二戰以後
那長期都分散在外務防衛
或者法務警察不同部門
那高市這一次一覽大全
將整合各部會的情報來提出綜合分析
主要推動日本改變的就是
周邊環境不一樣了
中國的壓力
俄羅斯的壓力
北韓的壓力
帶來的軍事和情報威脅持續升高
那日本以前都是靠CIA來供應情報
那又很擔心
未來總不能把情報跟國家安全
完全外包給華府
最後還是得自己解決
所以在上禮拜
高市早苗正式成立了國家情報局
那當然回過頭說
整體而言
在中太平洋
就是臺灣的部分
這緊張局勢也一直都沒有緩下來過
而臺灣局勢就是
臺灣人自己不是很緊張
國外就一直做專題很緊張
那的確
中國對臺的灰色地帶行動
正在從西側一路向東擴張
這是天下座的一個專題
來瞭解到底五六月份
我們看到的實質臺灣海峽周邊情況為何
那看得出來
中國海警的確已經把圍臺變成了執法的常態
威脅可能比軍演還要來得更為嚴重
因為你看在金馬海域
幾乎頻率一天大概就四艘到五艘
就每天就在那邊一直繞
繞進來趕走又繞回來
差不多就是這樣的一個態勢
那當然這會形成進一步的市場壓力
最終我們看到
整體無人機的發展
就在這種地緣政治緊張的局勢底下
被迫推波助瀾
川普在上禮拜也正式宣佈
對無人機課徵100%關稅
這說明美中的科技戰
已經完全延伸到低空經濟了
川普政府宣佈
對於進口無人機還有零組件
直接課徵100%關稅
其中重量超過25公斤
有特定敏感能力的無人機
直接試用最高稅率
一般小型無人機
如果是商用的就課25%就好了
但是有排外
歐盟 日本 瑞士 臺灣
不用課這麼高的關稅
只要課15%就好
英國是10%
那你要知道
現在美國商用無人機市場
最大的廠商是誰
就是大疆
所以大疆佔了70%
現在直接被課徵
接近100%的關稅
那這一次要賭的就不是整機了
就賭中國零組件
如果臺灣用中國零組件
照樣要課一樣的關稅
按比例來課徵
所以在這樣的一個效果底下
等於無人機大戰
已經正式開始了
那中方其實也主動宣佈
也要進行無人機的管制出口
雙方很明顯都在控制自己的籌碼
甚至在稀土戰層面
又開始蠢蠢欲動
美國當然是跟歐盟日本
來投入數百億美元
建立自己的關鍵礦物產業
可是中國最近又開始
逐步的收緊供應鏈政策
最近導致中國各類型的
關鍵礦物價格開始水漲船高
像總
總現在從25年以來
每公斤已經突破2800塊了
2022年它才500塊
烏的價格
現在因為中國已經幾乎停止供應給日本了
日本只好跟美國買
現在已經突破3000塊了
之前也才1000塊
所以從一系列材料價格的大漲
都已經看到美中之間的稀土戰
已經開始影響到鄰近的一些中小國家
那當然無人機產業的推行
就已經是勢在必行
現在美國有大量的訂單
向韓國向日本向中東
向烏克蘭來進行採購
不過雙方的量體差距還是非常大
如果我們就只看軍用無人機
現在中國的無人機
軍用無人機年產人
大概是300萬到800萬架
取決於有沒有出口到烏俄戰場
俄羅斯大概是500萬架到700萬架
烏克蘭是200萬架到500萬架
那必須承認
就算是烏克蘭
其實大部分
有一半以上也是中國運過去的
中國無人機
其實並沒有特別只供貨給俄羅斯
看起來是雙邊壓住
相對之下臺灣是多少
臺灣也很多
臺灣大概12萬架
在撇除正在打仗的幾國
在撇除中國
臺灣已經產量算高的
美國大概10萬架
土耳其12萬架
伊朗15萬架
日本就很誇張
日本大概只有1000架而已
跟臺灣甚至不是一個級別
這也點出現代戰爭的新現實
就是過去軍工比的都是
誰能夠造出最先進的戰機
飛彈還有軍艦
現在比的是誰能夠用最低成本
最快的速度
大量製造可以消耗的無人機
無人機一架很便宜
但是可以摧毀數十倍
甚至數百倍價值的裝備的時候
現在大量的生產能力
已經被美國視為重要的國防能力了
所以有時候我們要這樣想
的確從這個數據來看
那真的是落差很大
難怪美國這麼趕
也不商量
也不做逐步的關稅抬高
就直接就課程百分之百了
直接要停止
任何中國的領土艦進入到美國
開始瘋狂的跟臺灣跟日本
日本或者其他國家來進行採購
原因很簡單
因為有時候我們容易犯的錯
不是低估一件事情
是拿自己的尺度去衡量別人的世界
那投資世界也很一樣
就有些公司可能成長30%
你覺得很驚人
一個國家一年可以生產10萬架無人機
臺灣都已經生產的比美國多了
可是換一個競爭對手
換一個產業尺度
你才發現原來自己眼中的極限
只是別人的基本盤
所以你看那個數量就知道
的確臺灣美國那個生產無燃機的數量
跟中國的確它是不是同一個量級
臺灣已經創高了
對自己來講
但是跟中國目前的產量比較起來
非紅供應鏈仍然有很長一段路要走
最後還是取決於大家的尺度看的不同
這個時候要瞬間來進行調整
這些網絡上看
他講說有一個非洲男人
愛上一個白人千金
那女生的爸爸看不起他
你想娶我女兒
你先去哈佛拿學歷吧
結果男生真的去賭
半年之後
那非洲男真的拿到學歷了
那爸爸就說
那你一個月可以賺一千萬嗎
結果他真的去炒股票
炒到一個月可以賺一千萬
爸爸沒有招了
最後說
那最後一個條件
你那邊要有一公尺長
男的沉默了一下
為了你女兒
我撿
所以人最容易犯的錯
不是低估一件事情
而是拿自己的尺度
去衡量別人的世界
更進一步的來看
現在一個國家
他的武器夠不夠先進
另外一個國家想的可能是
我現在可以生產幾臺無人機
夠便宜夠快就可以了
現在投資尺度
對於軍事策略都是如此
所以你才可以看到
為什麼現在改變的速度
來得這麼快
突然之間關稅就已經擴增了
突然之間貨源就大量的來自歐拉臺
這是一個我們可以觀察到的
一個世界的大變局
感覺這個世界的變化越來越快了
那事實上我們看到這一次
前陣子我們不是看那個
Top Gun 2嗎
第六代戰機
上次拍電影還是第五代
現在第六代戰機已經陸續推出
而幾乎第六代戰機預估
都會採取無人聊機作戰
我們正常都是兩臺飛機要一起飛
要有聊機
那現在預估聊機會大量的使用
AI感測和數據系統
美方層面已經採取了
新一代的一個更換思維
臺灣其實也是如此
臺灣最值得觀察的就是中央總預算
上禮拜終於過關了
三了480億
三減幅度從6%降到1.68%
最重要的是什麼
是經濟部的無人機統籌計劃
80億預算全數過關了
與此同時有634億
接下來還會做細節探討
不過現在通過應該不會有什麼太大問題
上禮拜消息一出來
雷虎 漢祥 合成 亞航
軍工概念股市全面漲停
因為正式過關了
那一旦過關以後
代表的國防採購很快就會出來
有沒有機會能夠養出下一座的護國神山
我們當然不能說每一次都這麼樂觀
臺灣有很多國家隊的一個新建
以前有生技國家隊
有風電國家隊
必須承認生技國家隊的效果
沒有想象中來得這麼好
風電國家隊
效果也許沒有達到飛鴻供應鏈
不過臺灣是全球第五大的風電大國了
如果是從建制量來看的話
所以必須承認
一個新的國家隊的成立過程當中
難免會有一點質疑
不過既然朝野已經有共識
陸續過關以後
有兩個條件
一個就是產業的興起
各大縣市都開始搶錢了
那第二大呢
就是看一下
接下來美國的貨源
和訂單量幅度會有多大
因為人家是真的有需求
我們都不用靠自己
去爭取訂單的
人家的訂單
只要你有貨
現在正在瘋狂的下單
行政院這一次
是大概投入600億左右
那中央資源會落腳何處
已經引發各地政府的競爭
嘉義現在是有亞洲無人機
人工智慧創新研究中心
也是政府最先投入的國家基地
我們預估可以拿到最多錢
地方政府增最多的
主要還是來自於一些
包括2000億的國防自主的無人機採購
或者無人機無人艇的
21萬架的訂單
會由誰來拿
嘉義現在就是有集體優勢
臺中是精密製造和產業的劇弱
桃園有航空有電子和物流條件
現在預估應該是比照AI伺服器模式
各地都會拿到一筆資金
讓各地依照研發製造測試
和出口分工
來打造臺灣無人機的供應鏈
可是現在就不分藍綠了
所有縣市都在申請資金
希望可以獲得訂單
來扶植內部的企業
那的確臺灣無人機
現在最大的買家
去年大部分都是捷克
那捷克很明顯
買到之後馬上就進烏克蘭了
那今年在6月到7月
最大買家突然變成了
沙烏地阿拉伯
這個單月採購金額
就高達4720萬
這是23年以來的最高
一次就買了3000架
而且一架花很貴
一架買了1.45萬美元
是臺灣出口到其他國家
同類產品的十倍
所以臺灣莫名其妙
整個今年中旬無人機產業大爆發
因為中東正在瘋狂的採購
前兩年都靠烏二戰場在撐
現在靠中東戰場了
以後有什麼戰場
看起來打越多
臺灣無人機出口速度來得越快
國防部大概也啟動了
為期兩年
我說講是美國國防部
大概有11億美元
大概是360億美元的無人機的採購計劃
也就是在全球以美系訂單為準
預估會有數百億的資金鍊
會投散到全球各地
我們到時候就要看一下
臺灣能夠搶到多少訂單
當然我們做的不只是無人機
無人艇其實也是如此
臺灣大家知道
軍艦的確有高齡化的問題
現在臺灣95艘的軍艦當中
超過服務於50年以上的
已經有非常多了
大概有十幾艘
部分兩期或者後勤件
甚至可以追溯到二戰下水時期
二戰打到現在都還沒有退役
所以面對艦隊老化
目前到底是要更換新一輪的新艦
還是說可以把預算撥去
採購大量的無人艇
這也是未來可以觀察的幾大方向
但不管怎麼說
一個新的時代已經開始了
我們今天聊的範圍比較廣
臺股上漲339點
收在46156點
一方面我們先聊
美國股市漲到這樣的一個位階以後
市場的擔憂和他的信心在哪裡呢
擔憂當然是利率環境
仍然不利於這些企業繼續的融資
可是信心來自於
他真的賺那麼多錢
所以他的本益比例並不高
他沒有想象中這麼貴
那第二件事情
看的是整個通膨的傳導
在每一衝突持續僵局底下
原油價格是按在80多塊左右
可是已經外溢出去了
大量的大宗資產價格
今年已經外溢下去
可能會導致通膨下行陸續
沒有想象中來得快
他不至於升息
你要讓他降息
其實也是困難重重必須承認
第三件事情
來自於地緣政治的動盪
它雖然對於利率環境有影響
它的好處是什麼
它的好處是
全球無人機產業鏈已經逐步到位
而臺灣現在是
非中非二非烏體系當中
產量第一名的經濟體了
目前整體甚至領先於南韓日本市場
和其他土耳其市場
自己就說明著
一個國家隊的成立
我們當然知道
大家給它比較高的一個檢視標準
但是也許一個新的商機
也會因此而出現
給投資朋友做一些參考
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就明天早上8點半
早晨財經速解讀再相見
祝各位投資朋友看盤順利
操盤愉快